lutely incredible and to tell you what's
coming to blades
let me introduce project leader Craig
Lafferty and art director Matt Cara fado
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks Bob it's great to be here at e3
and thanks again to all of you for
making blades number one as someone
who's worked on the elder scrolls for 20
years it's been incredible to bring this
world to your phones in an all new way
we still love those classic dungeon
crawlers and it's clear you do as well
and whether you're exploring a dungeon
or rebuilding your town it's great to be
able to do it wherever you are since its
e3 we're releasing our biggest update
yet featuring all new jobs and solo
arena battles an all new custom jewelry
system and a brand new Dragon Quest line
it has even more but best of all it's
coming out tonight
so download free tonight and give it a
try and we're all so hard at work on our
arena mode for this fall that will
feature PvP your own guild and visiting
your friends towns but most exciting
this year we're also bringing blades to
an all-new platform switch blades
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes blades is coming this fault in the
Nintendo switch and yes it's still free
blades is the perfect fit for the switch
you can play on the go on your TV and
with motion controls but best of all
it's cross play and cross progression
with the mobile version so you can so
you can start tonight on mobile and all
your progress will carry over and it's
playable here at e3 in our booth and
Nintendo's yeah
and for those of you playing on mobile
we also have some special rewards for
both our Apple and Google players this
week so download tonight and let us know
what you think thanks again now let me
introduce Jeff and Tom to tell you
what's coming to